Okay.
So without further ado,
can you please give a warm welcome to
today's speaker, Christina and rush.
[inaudible].
Thank you very much. Can
everybody hear me okay? Yeah.
So it's such a pleasure to be here.
Thank you very much. They will welcome.
I'm a child and family psychotherapist,
so I work with families from various
backgrounds with various difficulties.
Um,
but the other things that I do is I like
to talk to people about what the code
research says about brain development
in children for babies and children.
Um, because I think this is information
that should be available to every petite,
not just psychologists, therapists,
medical professional, social workers.
It's information that we all know.
It can make an enormous difference to how
we live our lives in our relationships
with not just with our children, but
also with each other, with our partners,
with our friends,
with our extended family.
So what I'm going to talk to you about
today extends across many different
aspects of our lives. Um, and, uh,
I hope you go away feeling informed,
but also inspired,
uh,
in what you bring to other people,
to your relationships in your life.
Because I'm going to be talking about
the importance of those relationships far
our physical and our mental health.
So we know now from all the
research in neuroscience that,
um,
uh,
charge brain development is very much
dependent on the quality of the social
relationships that that child has
in their lives. And the child's,
the foundations of the brain are very
much built on those relationships,
what they bring to the child
and how they manifest, um,
as, as impact on the brain.
So I'll be talking about that.
So the aim of the presentation is really
to talk to you about the neuroscience
and how emotional visibility and the
input in terms of the relation relational
quality of the apples around the
child have a powerful impact on the
neurochemistry,
the neurobiology.
So the structural aspects of brain
development, the neurochemical,
so how the hormones and chemicals respond
in our brains and in our bodies and
overall how that influences the structural
development of the brain bundles.
So the social,
emotional and cognitive development.
Just before I get going, or
if you just wanted to, uh,
I'm curious about what brought
many of you here today.
So would anybody be willing to say,
if you had a question in your mind that
you with you that you'd like to explore?
Yeah.
Hi. Um, we, I have two
young toddlers at home.
They're two and three and they're in
crashed part time when we're thinking my
putting them into crash full time.
And I don't know if being in a crash
in these formative years we'll have any
negative impact. And it's something that
that does kind of concern is Maria. So,
wow. So for me, it's Ryan, I suppose
if we're not available as parents,
does it, does that have any kind of
impact? That's a good question. Thank you.
Anybody else?
Yeah, the three young kids and, um,
just obviously interested
in the neuroscience son,
their direct development,
but also just curious as to,
um,
how the relationship between the parents
can impact the children and any of the
science around that.
That could be useful.
Okay, great. So I'm
just going to just, uh,
to hold those questions.
That's the penny or somewhere.
So we have less than an hour left.
Um,
so I'm just going to,
uh,
capture that as parents together and
then, uh, young children and crashes.
MMM.
Just so because of the
limited time we have,
we won't be able to go into
any of this in great detail,
but hopefully I'll be able
to touch on it for you. Um,
in talking about the, uh, what it
is that shapes brain development.
Okay.
So the jury is in that we know that
we need each other people need people.
That's how we develop in a healthy way,
both physically and emotionally.
And I do add in physical,
because there's quite a few
studies now across the world, um,
that demonstrate the importance of
emotional health for physical health.
So relationships build brains, minds.
We know that, we know that, um,
from the neural science and the buyer,
the research into biochemistry,
but actually relationships come
to regulate our nervous systems.
So they come to bring us into
emotional balance if they work well.
And that's because our hormonal
systems sync with each other.
And, but this is particular important
for infants, for babies. Uh, and I'll be,
uh, uh, elaborating on
this as we go along.
But for babies and for all of us,
you know,
the idea of being in sync with each
other, no, if you heard of that, um,
it is in terms of being emotionally and
think it means how neuro biologically by
chemically we're in with each other.
That's how our systems are
connecting on that level.
And biochemistry is like electricity.
We can't see it, but we know it exists.
Right? Does everybody convinced
electricity exists by now?
Um,
so it's interesting.
There are all these chemical processes
going on that affect us with each other,
but we don't,
we don't know what's happening,
but certainly the research has
been able to substantiate that. Um,
and the more so a little,
uh,
proposition that I'm throwing at you
today is the more individualistic we
become, the more anxious than
depressed we've become as humans.
And there's plenty of evidence to
demonstrate that social isolation. It has,
uh, holds the biggest threat
to our mental health. And, um,
you may well know that the greatest
form of torture is what solitary
confinement.
And it's used for a reason because it
really has such a detrimental impact on us
as human beings. Um, relationships
heal troubled brains.
We also know that from the research into
how therapy works and actually across
thousands of a therapeutic approaches,
there wasn't very many,
many models of therapy.
What we know,
the common denominator in terms of what
makes a difference is the quality of the
relationship between the
practitioner and the client.
And actually I would say that goes
for any professional. If you go to GP,
if your GPA is not
particularly relational,
if will be a very different
experience and outcome for you.
Would you agree with that?
And there is a lot of research into
the relationship with the medical
practitioner and how
that can impact and how,
whether we get better and
how quickly we get better.
So that's all that's really interesting.
Um,
and we're all in as resilient as humans,
as the people we're connected to.
So we're all both
vulnerable and resilient.
So it's not the one person is
resilient another innocent.
But it depends on many factors.
So resilience is actually
a social phenomenon rather
than just about the grips
that you have as a human being.
I've got that comes into it and how
you develop your capacity to be able to
bounce back from stress and challenge.
But without other people around us.
Actually we won't.
We will not be particularly resilient.
And something very important,
which is actually widely known
in research in education,
but it's not necessarily mirrored in our
educational systems as they function on
the ground,
is that learning is a social experience.
Children learn from people they like.
Would you agree with that?
From your experience in school, you didn't
have a relationship with the teacher?
How well did you do with that subject?
Yeah,
so in terms of how we take on new skills,
new information, new
knowledge, new awareness,
those relationships are really key and
what we're seeing now in terms of people
who have a developmental health problems,
what makes a difference is not somebody
painting your diagnosis on them and
telling them what's wrong with them,
but it's actually people coming
together as a group in the community.
And thinking about their strengths and
thinking about what it is that empowers
them to be able to overcome the challenges
that they're facing with their mental
health. So the facts from
neuroscience about babies brains,
and we've got a little exhibit
over here in the corner,
is that babies are born with
a hundred billion neurons.
Did you know that?
That's a lot of neurons rights,
but they're not connected. That's the
thing. There are there in the brain,
but they're not connected yet.
And so the waiting and they need that
social experience in order to connect the
need, that interaction with
the adults around the baby,
the baby needs that in order for
those connections to get made.
And by the age of, um, three,
what we're finding from neuroscience is
that about 85 to 90% of a baby's brain
is connected. So that's why the
first three years are so vital
and that baby's experience is going
to have a big impact on how they move
forward.
So we're talking about foundation,
a foundational development of the brain.
Now it's important to know that actually
not all is lost if a baby has a poor
experience.
Um,
some babies are born into families
where parents are not available,
not able emotionally to take care of them
because they have maybe drug problems,
alcohol problems.
So with ever depression gets in the way
and through no fault of the parent to no
fault of their own, it can make
it difficult for them to connect.
And for those babies,
if they do have a poor start,
the science shows that actually those,
those connections can develop,
play to run if the baby has the
experience of the input for that.
So we also know from science
that the brain is like a muscle.
If we don't use it,
we lose it.
And certainly in Airlie development are
babies born with far more neurons than
they actually need.
And so if they're not being stimulated,
the baby's not having a variety of social,
emotional,
cognitive experiences,
physical experiences than
those neurons don't connect up.
And actually what the neuroscience says,
they actually die away. They, they, they,
um, uh, wither and die if
they're not stimulated, not used.
And also
it's interesting because we're,
I think we're living in a world,
we have been certainly through the
of the nineties, the, the era of,
of kind of the frontal brain and
thinking a lot about talking a lot about
cognition as rational thinking, but
actually what the science is saying now,
it's the social, uh, uh, influence,
the social experience and maybe has that
has the greatest impact on the quality
of brain development.
And we know that the bay,
the brain builds from the base upwards.
So you have your very primitive
brain here at the back.
So baby's not born with the
higher structures built yet,
but they have the deeper
emotional structures.
And within that we have our primitive
brain, but also our emotional brain.
We know, you know, only too well,
that babies cry a lot, don't they?
Not Yours. Oh Wow. You're
very lucky. You're very lucky.
Not every parent will
have had that experience,
but babies cried from the primitive
brain because they're terrified.
They've never been here
before. Actually, that depends.
What do you believe in reincarnation or
not? But, um, when I say, uh, they've,
they don't know what to do.
They need the adults to guide them,
to give them information,
to help them make sense of
their experience in order
to feel safe and secure.
And so babies will work from
that primitive brain and
cry when things are scary
or the anxious or their
heart are in need of care.
Um,
and these circuits which are in the
deeper primitive brain and the emotional
brand there,
the structure is on which later brain
development gets built and how those
structures are actually nurtured in the
first three years particularly is very
important, uh, as, as
I'll go on to talk about,
so that's a little picture of your brain.
That's the one side.
Uh,
if somebody took a chainsaw
and cut your head and half,
I hope that never happens to anybody in
the soldiers. And that's what you'll see.
And I'm here.
You've got these deeper structures,
so it's not coming up very well with the,
so here you've got the deeper structures,
the primitive brain and
that that goes across here.
And down here is the emotional brain.
The limbic brain is called.
And in that you've got this
structure called the Amygdala,
which is the alarm system.
And if you are frightened or if
you're anxious or if you're angry,
and some positive emotions are
connected to the mental as well,
but very much connected with fear and
anxiety and threatened the ed experiences
that where you perceived threat, you're
a middle and we'll go off to your alarm.
It's like the alarm in your house,
a fire alarm or your burglar alarm.
If something feels threatening, the alarm
will go off. And that will put you into,
you know this I'm sure fight,
flight or freeze. Yeah.
And that propels you to react in
order to survive and protect yourself.
That's how we take care of,
take care of ourselves as humans.
And it's how we survive.
So baby doesn't actually
have the higher brain.
So the part across the top and at the
front here is called the prefrontal
cortex. Well, the whole, the whole
structure is called the cortex.
But this here is particularly
important is the prefrontal cortex.
And that's the part of the
brain that used to think,
reflect. What else might you
use it for? You think? Planning,
grades,
anything else?
Learning. Yes. Processing
information. Yep.
Sorry.
Predict. Brilliant. Yeah.
So to predict things,
to be able to analyze information and
then make predictions to draw conclusions.
Yeah.
Uh,
so we've got problem
solving in there as well.
Impulse control,
emotional regulation.
So we need this part of our brain
to help to regulate our emotions.
So you can see how important it is that
the frontal lobe is connected to the
Amygdala, particularly that
limbic part of the brain.
Because those two parts of the
brain need to work in tandem.
Well for us to be able
to manage ourselves,
particularly around our more primitive
emotions are impulse desiring something
in a moment. And you know, if we
make a rash decision, that's it,
I'm going to have it.
That might,
that'll be the primitive brain making
the decision rather than you thinking
actually,
is this the right thing for me right now?
Or is this a good thing to do as a
an honorable thing to do or whatever.
So that helps us to make
moral choices as well.
Okay.
So that's just to give you
a picture of uh, the growth,
the development of neuronal connections
from a newborn to adulthood.
That's, this is the adult one here. This
is covered. So you can see the, the,
the rapid development of connections that
happen and this is healthy development
where a baby is interacted
with and stimulated.
You see how those neuronal connections
get made and how they become abundant
because the more stimulation,
and now I have to qualify this because we,
we can,
I don't want any of you going home and
suddenly going to the library and getting
20 bucks and doing that sort of what to
call that flash thing with your child,
where you're showing them lots of
flashcards. It doesn't work like that.
The stimulation Ni as
I'll explain in a minute,
needs to be attuned to the baby.
And that's the problem
about going in with,
let's give them more stimulation
and then they'll get triple A's in,
they're living starch when they're done.
It doesn't work like that.
So the stimulation is important.
But how does stimulate with comes in is
really crucial because what we could do
is we can overwhelm the baby's brain
with stimulation and they could feel too
much.
And I'll talk about that in a minute.
So let's have a look at this video or
some of it just aware of time is going
very quickly.
There's lots of things I want to show you.
So this is to show you the importance
of social connection for a baby.
Um, so the baby's speaking for themselves
and it shows you what happens if that
social connection gets taken away.
So it's,
it's an experiment that was created by
psychologists about 35 years ago to try
and get into the experience of the
baby rather than trying to do lots of,
you know, crunching lots of numbers,
really very much a social, emotional,
qualitative type of research.
So any thoughts about that?
Are using their phones?
Phones?
Yeah,
I think I'm using the tablets and all that
kind of stuff on is they're saying no,
the kids are trying to best to get your
attention and you're just stuck in it.
So I think that's what
it made me think of.
Do you think about that? Yeah. Great. So
we can get preoccupied is adults, right?
And the reason I'm here is because people
need to know this information and once
you have inflammation you
can be more aware, right?
I don't blame parents
for getting it wrong,
but I think a good, I'm a parent
and my, my son's one grown up now,
but if I had this
information 33 years ago,
I think life would be a lot easier for
him now. But we learn and we can only,
what I say to the parents I work with,
we can only work with the information
we have at any moment in time.
Our parents,
some of us who are older were told,
I mean my mum was told to push this down
the end of the field and leave us in
the fresh air cause would make our
lungs stronger. So when we were crying,
nobody heard us and nobody came.
I've been in therapy since,
so, uh, so parents, you know, are,
might not be aware and might be distracted
and work can be very demanding as all
sorts of reasons why parents can get
taken away from their babies and their
children. So, uh, his, here's the,
here's the science. Yeah. Anybody
else want to comment on that?
I mean,
apart from the parents kind of
shutting down in terms of reaction,
what's the difference?
I have two young boys by the way. I'm
like, for example, in the mornings,
so we're getting ready. It's a mad house
and what we actually do quite regularly,
okay. You know, there's an Ipad,
whatever cartoon of the flavor of
the month design in the moment,
the two of them, two and a half
year old and a one year old will,
we'll shut up and watch the screen and
they'll be happy while we, you know,
get dressed and get out the
door with them. Is there, is
that different, does that,
is that like, because it's not
an actual human interaction,
is that as as as ugly a thing?
So it's about the frequency
of being in contact,
out of contact. That's the issue. So it's
not whether you do, I mean, you know,
let's face it, as parents, you have to
find strategies to manage. You know,
you're a busy day. The demand, you've got
to get out to work. That's the reality.
Um, and so if you, if you
use a video, you know,
in the moment to help, you
know, keep the children from,
you know, running out the front door
or are climbing the walls or whatever,
that's, that's different from actually
children who are on screens incessantly or
parents who are on screens incessantly.
I'll go on to talk about what it is about
the social interaction that's so key.
So, um, parenting just
needs to be good enough.
Is there a sigh of relief in the room? It
doesn't have to be perfect. And in fact,
as I'll talk about perfect parenting,
so called, there's not such thing,
but her parents want to be perfect. It
can be detrimental to their children. So,
you know, uh, think about what
I'm saying and then, you know,
balance it out. Have a discussion and
think, you know, is this, is this okay?
You probably is. If it's only in a
moment to get the job done. Yeah.
Okay. So you, some of you might have
been surprised by that baby's response.
You know,
I don't traditionally have assumed that
babies were born with what's known as a,
a kind of blank slate as a blank
slate, Tabula Rasa, um, you know,
like a computer that just arrives
at your home. Uh, that's not been,
uh, uh, what you call it here.
Uh, programs. So that's
the idea. You know, I,
I'm not very computer
literate. I have to admit. Um,
technology terrifies me most of the time,
but actually it's very much,
the previous thinking was very much like
that the baby arrives like the laptop,
the good comes in the post and I turn
it on and expect to just to work,
not realizing it has to be programmed.
So we know now the babies are actually
born with innate capacities for
interacting and connecting,
which have a profound effect on their
development and how that's responded to.
And just in case you think this
is just a female phenomenon,
I want to show you this. It's
a bit a bit of this video. Um,
because you know,
traditionally women have been seen as the,
as the important caregivers,
uh,
for babies and young children,
but actually dad,
so just as important, it's a bad
relationship. It's not about your,
your gender.
Um,
it's about the quality of the
relationship you bring to this child.
So why not,
what is it the parents do
that builds that baby's brain?
And we know from the research
there are five main things,
so five,
uh,
building blocks of the brain
or a formula if you like,
a different type of formula, power from
their feeding formula, feeding the brain,
uh,
in this case so the parent responds,
so a baby and a child will
initiate when they want connection.
So maybe connection just
to play and have some fun.
It may be connection for stimulation
because they're bored or it may be
connection,
uh,
because they want to be calmed down and
suited and helped with their feelings
because they can't do it for themselves.
And so in order for a parent
respond appropriately,
what's very important is that the parent
is able to read the cues of the baby or
the child.
Oh,
I wonder if she's crying because she's
needs a nappy change or maybe she's
hungry,
maybe she's bored.
Or maybe she's very frightened because
there was just a loud noise went off next
door. And that's really, really key.
And that asks for your intuitive judgment.
So your brain connecting with your body
to help you to attune and empathize with
what it is that the baby is needing.
And actually for new parents
that can take time, right?
When you have first have a
baby, it's like, oh my God,
what do I do with this? Um,
for all parents.
But you get into the baby's rhythm,
you get to know your baby,
your baby gets to know you and you
actually learn the baby's temperament,
which is very important because
no two babies are the same.
And that's very important.
If any of you have gone,
if you go onto the internet
to use parenting books
because sometimes the blogs
and the books will actually present
stock responses for all babies controlled
crying. It's one of them when
the child is older. Timeout.
But actually if our babies and
our children are individual,
they will need an individual
response, which is, uh,
comes from the moment from you perceiving
what it is that they actually need
from you.
So we need to notice the baby's needs
and read those cues and then respond to
pro APP as a CI tuned way as
possible. It doesn't, again,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
And then the second element of,
uh,
what a parent does is to use contact.
So for,
for young babies,
we picked them up and with color
color them and we hold them a lot.
And we know from research by the
age of about six to nine months,
babies start to need less and less,
uh,
picking up and holding, but they still
need contact and neither us to, to,
um, to give them cuddles, to comfort
them when they're distressed. Um,
but as a child develops that,
that need for a con
consumer holding reduces.
Um, and uh, and that physical contact,
that touch is absolutely vital for the
brain and the body to develop two to wire
up, but also for those feel good hormones
to come in. So we've got oxytocin,
dopamine,
Serotonin,
dopamine is a very important
hormone for learning and for,
for focus and attention. And, uh,
oxytocin, I don't know if you know,
but it's labeled the
love hormone. So we, we,
we stimulate the air.
We secrete oxytocin when we come into
any loving or intimate contact with
another person. So it could be a
lovely experience with a friend.
It doesn't have to be a romantic partner,
but parents and children's stimulate
the production of oxytocin in each other
when they interact in joyful,
a interactive experiences.
Um, the other important thing about
the touches actually helps us to, uh,
learn to, uh, feel
ourselves in our bodies.
And that kind of might seem a
bit of a strange thing to say,
but really a feeling embodied,
putting grounded in your own body
and connected to all of your organs.
Because a lot of our emotions,
uh,
that our ability to perceive our emotions
comes from our viscera. They come,
the Vegas nerve passes right down
from the brain into our vital organs,
lungs, throat, uh, kidneys, stomach,
and an order for us to be able to know
how we feel and to be able to then
communicate that we need to be
able to perceive those emotions.
And if we're cut off, my buddies
weren't able to do that. So the third,
uh, element of, of, of, uh,
what up for the parent does to build
the baby's brain is actually how they
manage their own emotions.
So a parent being able to regulate
themselves are ourselves homework,
upset, distressed, angry, that
before we respond to our baby,
we check how am I feeling? Oh,
well, I'm feeling really angry.
Maybe now's not the time
for me to deal with this.
So maybe I'll get my
partner to deal with it.
And so it's just going to
this slide to show you,
it's the idea of securing your
own oxygen mask before you secure.
As you know,
when you're on an airplane and they say,
put your own oxygen mask on
before you put on your chiles.
And I've always taught that
sounded counterintuitive.
But when you think about it,
actually you can't save somebody else
unless you're actually protected yourself.
So similarly with your own
emotions, you can't regulate, um,
uh, a baby or a child, a young
child unless you're regulated.
Because remember what I said about the
neuro chemicals. Have they, uh, get, uh,
triggered? How'd they get stimulated
between us, between our brains,
our two brains interacting with
each other and our bodies too.
If we're angry or we're very anxious,
then the baby or the child's
neuro biological system
will pick that up and those
corresponding emotions
will be triggered in them.
So really paying attention to
our own arousal levels, uh,
and trying to calm ourselves down in
order to be able to come them down is very
important. And actually what's really
key to know is that babies actually learn
to regulate their, not just their
emotions, but their whole rhythms,
circadian rhythms through the physical
holding from the parents. I met,
I met all of these five things actually
for particularly the physical holding.
So when a baby cries,
a,
that will trigger some discomfort in
new quite naturally as parent because
that's nature's way of making sure that
you don't sit and continue watching game
of Thrones on TV, that you
actually respond to the baby.
Otherwise you might not.
So we are made uncomfortable,
which propels us into responding.
And then what happens is as we hold the
baby and we start to calm the baby and
sued the baby are Razah level
comes down and the baby finds out,
ah, that's how you calm down. This
is, oh, that's very interesting.
Obviously not because babies
don't have condition yet,
but the baby's system learns.
It's a training procedure.
This is how you calm down.
Watch Mommy,
watch daddy as mommy and daddy calm down.
The baby's system gets that
information and over and over and over,
true time,
the baby's system,
a babies rounds of system,
you're a biological system.
Brain body is able to do that for
themselves when they get, it's a stressed,
anxious subset. So does that
make sense? So we don't,
we don't, we're not born with the
capacity to emotionally regulate.
We have to learn it.
And we learned it as babies and young
children from the adults around us
regulating themselves and
then showing us how it's done.
You can imagine if a parent, you
know, and you all parents get angry,
I get frustrated and get anxious.
That's quite natural.
But as long as it's not
continuous and all the time,
then that's not going to have a
detrimental effect on the child. But,
um, you can imagine being around
somebody who's very angry all the time.
What does that do to you? What does the,
how does that make your system fail?
I not just talking about your thoughts,
but also your whole big,
what does that feel like?
Would you imagine?
And not food.
He might feel threatened and
undressed under attack as a,
put you one kind of defense in
a defensive mode because it's,
what's happening is those stress hormones
are cascading round your body because
there'd been triggered by the
other person's level of emotions.
And that's why it's so important that
we're really thinking about it on
regulation.
Uh,
as we're looking after our babies and
our children and of course each other,
because similarly you will have a similar,
uh,
experience with a partner of friends.
If they're constantly disregulated,
then you're going to pick that
up and you're going to feel that.
And then the fourth component of
what pens to is clay now playing,
we all know it's a good
idea to play with the child.
But here we're not just talking
about in know, playing together,
playing a board game together or uh,
reading the mystery or,
um, playing a board game.
We're talking about right from
the very beginning with an infant,
the face to face interaction that happens
between parents and child and how that
has a huge impact on how
the brain connects up.
So when you see a baby and you
go to interact with a baby,
what do you find yourself doing?
Have you noticed if some of you might
not have been around a baby recently,
but what do you notice yourself doing?
You lean in. What else do you do?
You smile, you make, well,
they don't think they're silly.
I don't think they're silly,
but we start to make these noises.
He sounds, what are the, sounds like?
Does anybody want to do a demonstration?
So you raise the pitch of your voice.
Very important. What else do you do?
Expressing you become more expressive.
Your face.
You saw that mom when she may engage,
she was very animated.
So you and you look excited,
interested and excited.
Very important.
You start to intimate your words,
you elongate them.
Um,
and you do a rhythmical
voice. Oh No. Could you,
aren't you so good today?
Has Anybody talked to the
partner like that? Believe me,
I had some people living in my house
once and they did and it was really
irritating, but mostly adults. Dope.
But we'd find ourselves as an innate
drive to do that with babies isn't
interesting because it's called
infant directed speech in,
in science.
But we talk about parenting.
These are baby talk.
But it's so important because it's the
building blocks of social interaction.
Babies learn.
One had to make eye contact.
They learn how to turn take. So
I have a goal. You have a goal.
My turn. Your turn. What,
what is that important for?
Having conversations where people,
social conversations,
do you know people who don't
try and take very well? Yeah.
Um, so that is very important because
it helps us to connect the timing.
All of that needs very precise judgment.
And babies learned that from their
parents doing that face to face.
They also learn about how to
read other people's emotions.
So if I'm looking at you and you look sad,
no, you're doing it right
there. So if you're a baby,
I might sit all that and
what I do as a parent,
as an adult, if I'm emotionally
attuned and I'm an empathic,
I'll display that emotion on my face and
then we'll get reflected back to you.
And what I'd be saying too is I get
it. I get it. You're really sad.
The baby feels great when that
happens, as opposed to, Oh,
you look really happy. The
baby's like, no, I'm not.
But they can't tell us that. But they
might cry because we didn't get them.
That's called misattunement.
So when we do that, oh,
you look so sad. We're giving them
the information about that emotion.
This was what's sad. Looks like you're
sad. I'm resonating with the emotion.
That's the empathy.
And I teach my child how to
understand their own emotions,
how to read other people's emotions
and how to develop the vocabulary.
Sad.
So now I have a word for sad because my
mommy and my daddy tells me what's sad
is, Oh, if you're not coming with the
feed quickly enough and the baby's crying.
Angalee and my said, oh, you're
really angry with mommy or daddy,
but you're not angry
when you're saying that.
But you're helping the baby to
understand what that emotion is.
All of that and much more comes from
those face to face interactions,
which are so key.
And then we have talk, which
is the conversation, the words,
the language. And you can see how
these are all interlinked. You know,
we do all of these in the blank for now.
We don't break them down and say,
right now I'm going to talk to you.
We actually do everything we, we
look and we go on to. So beautiful.
We start to use the language.
And we use the,
the infant directed
speech because that is,
gives the baby the basis of language.
It's cold,
they're cold protal conversations
where we're having this conversation.
You make a sound,
I echo back the sound to you.
Like you might say God got guys,
babies often say not yet but it's coming.
Um, and so I was attuned. Parents
do is they reflect back the sun,
the mirror, the sand back
to the baby, go, go, go.
And that is the building
blocks of language teachers,
a baby about the social, particularly
the social aspects of language.
But there's so much more in there with
the play in the top because it says your
really important,
you're a valuable human being.
You are deserving of my time and
attention and my focus and I'm really
interested in you. So the excitement
is a really key part of this.
The animation, because I'm saying
to my baby, I so interested in,
in you and I really love
interacting with you.
You failed that and that
affects your physiology.
It affects the babies for the
physiology and your mirror each other.
And that is a perfect storm for
communication. This works well.
Is there any science around the, uh,
uh, affect that younger siblings? Yeah,
because I,
my third child definitely got
way less than my first or,
or even second child because
you're so busy. Yeah. Yeah.
With the other older ones.
Yeah.
And I was nine of 12,
so I know what you're
talking about. Um, yeah,
I guess it's difficult when you're, the
more children you have, the more your, um,
demands there are on your
resources, your intention, your
focus, your time, your, uh,
you know, your capacity or energy. That's
the hard thing about being parents.
I've been having a number of children.
Um,
I don't know specifically
about research in relation.
There's lots of research on
sibling. Uh, I'm on birth order.
Um, and you know, there are differences,
uh, in relation to that. Um,
but you know, when I want you
to go away with is knowing this,
but also knowing that, um, children
just need enough, you know,
we need to be just good enough as parents.
And one of the problems currently
it's called helicopter parenting,
where parents are so hyper
anxious about being good enough,
they're actually hampering their
child's development. So you know,
this is why the first three years is
so key because you're building the
foundations of a house.
I was creating the structural foundations,
which then the house gets built on
strong foundations and then you'll have a
strong house. So as children, uh,
we know from the research that,
um,
children need to start cutting amount to
have babies even needs a certain amount
of challenge to be able
to learn to be resilient.
So when mom stopped talking to
this baby and the baby got upset,
that wasn't damaging for that baby.
It would have been if
mom hadn't come back.
What happened was the baby started to
use their resources to just see what was
going on with the baby. What
would they, what was she doing?
She was trying to get mum back.
So she was raising her hands.
They played the game. So in her
memory systems, there's this game,
this work before this has helped
us connect. Um, she points,
she does a number of things and then
she does something called amplification.
She starts to increase the
intensity of her communication,
her voice and her body language. Because
if you're not getting it, the child,
you know this, I mean have you have
young children, they will up the ante.
And that's because it's so terrifying
to be disconnected from your parent and
you're, you're afraid as a small
charge. You don't have the, the, uh,
mechanisms to be able to think, actually
daddy's gone. But he's coming back.
I mean,
that takes some time to develop that on
that security and that understanding or
daddy's going to never
got to talk to me again.
Fear is of abandonment and of
losing a parent's love. So, um,
important to know that resilience is
built from a certain amount of challenge.
So what Phil's resilience for this child
is that she is trying these different
things to get mom back and then mum
responds and that helps her to feel
masterful.
It helps her to feel I can have
an effect on somebody else.
See what I can do and my mommy's
not paying attention to me,
I can get mum back. So what's important
is that it becomes predictable,
um,
that the parent has read
the baby's signals or the
child signals and accurately
and emotionally attuned. Oh,
I'm sorry I was there somewhere.
I think my head was somewhere else.
I'm sorry I wasn't listening to you.
What did you want to tell me?
Isn't that what we do as parents?
And so it's not coming back in and
really acknowledging the child's,
uh, effort. It's all you really
wanted to get my attention.
That helps the child to feel,
yeah, I could get my money
back and my dad did back.
I can make things happen.
So what's important is the repair is the
reconnection between parent and child.
So, you know, if you lose the
connection temporarily, that's okay.
It just needs to be repaired.
If you shout at your child,
would you will do cause you're
human. Yeah. Right then,
I'm sorry I shouted at
you mummies. Uh, you know,
having a bad day today and I shouldn't
have showed them sorry for doing that.
That's what builds resilience, not the
fact that you're never shatter your child,
but that you shouted and you repaired.
So we're just about to finish. Um,
but that, that uh, what I was saying,
yeah, you're right about the stimulation.
Assimilation needs to be in tune.
So as you're interacting with your babies
or your child is reading their body
language.
So if we're bombarding them
with flashcards because we
want them to do better in
English, I'd leaving cert and there are
gone of cringing and tried to pull away.
That's a communication that
they're overwhelmed. It's too much,
it's too difficult.
Um,
so constantly reading body language and
the cues that are given off so that we
can actually work out how much to engage,
how often for how long, um,
is the most helpful thing.
And as I said, well, it's
really empowering for a baby.
The small child is that they
know they have an impact on you.
If they try to connect with you and
you respond, that's very empowering.
If they lose you when you come back,
that's very empowering and
that is what builds resilience.
So Dan Siegel lose an American
psychologist, a psychotherapist says,
we now know that the way to help a child
develop optimally is to help her create
connections in our brain or whole brain
adaptive about skills that lead to
better relationships, better mental
health, and more, uh, meaningful lives.
You could call it brain sculpting or
brain building, whatever phase you prefer.
The point is crucial and trilling as
a result of the words we use and the
emotions we take,
children's brains will actually change
and be built as they undergo new
experiences.
And that leaves a positive note
that the brain is plastic for life.
Very important for somebody
of my age to know that.
But we have periods of growth
and proliferation and so
we reorganization between
about 11 and 24 but the brain can change,
change the experience of the outside
world and the brain will change,
change the way we interact with
children and their brains will change.
Thank you all very much for this.
[inaudible].